عندما يكون الأطفال في المنزل
وتبدأ الرغبة الشديدة بعد المدرسة
في ذلك لا يجب أن يكون وصفة
لتناول الوجبات السريعة ،
حاول تحضير عصير للأطفال
بدلاً من ذلك يمكن أن يكون لذيذًا
ومغذيًا عند صنعه من الفراولة
ومضادات الأكسدة الموجودة في الفراولة  يمكن أن
تساعد في تعزيز جهاز المناعة لديك
أو جرب البطاطا الحلوة لإضافة المزيد من
الزنج
حاول مزج البطاطا الحلوة والقرنبيط
وزبدة اللوز ثم أضف بعض
التوابل المفضلة لديك مثل القرفة وجوزة الطيب
أو الفانيليا ،
هذا العصير مليء بالبروتين
والألياف التي يمكن أن تساعد الأطفال  ابقَ
ممتلئًا لفترة أطول ، ويمكن أن يقدم نخب الأفوكادو
وجبة خفيفة رائعة
للأطفال الأكبر سنًا ، فالأفوكادو مليء
بالدهون الصحية والألياف
للأطفال الأصغر سنًا.
وبروتين بناء
العضلات وغسله ، قدم الماء على
العصائر
والمشروبات الغازية وغيرها من المشروبات السكرية